♪ WE DO KNOW THAT DONALD
TRUMP SR. HAS LIED
THROUGHOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> THIS GOES TO THE HEART OF
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE COLLUSION AND THE
COVERUP.
>> I ALSO THINK THERE IS A
VERY STRONG ARGUMENT TO BE
MADE THAT THIS IS A HIGH
CRIME OR MISDEMEANOR FOR
WHICH IMPEACHMENT MAY BE A
POSSIBILITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S TWEET
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN SCRIPTED
BETTER IF IT WAS WRITTEN BY
PUTIN HIMSELF.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS GOING
THERE TO MEET WITH HIS
HANDLER.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS
SURRENDERED TO RUSSIA.
>> Bret: WELL, JUST SOME OF
THE REPORTING LEADING UP TO
THE MUELLER REPORT WAS QUITE
WIDE OFF THE MARK.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME IS HERE WITH SOME
LESSONS LEARNED, PERHAPS,
IT'S BEEN A LONG YEAR AND 10
MONTHS, BRIT.
BRIT BRIT IT HAS, INDEED.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, BRIT.
THIS INVESTIGATION ACTUALLY
GOES BACK TO THE MIDDLE OF
2016.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR QUITE
A LONG TIME.
AND THIS ENDLESS SPECULATION
ABOUT IT INDEED THE
ACCUSATIONS ABOUT IT THAT
CAME OUT OF MANY MOUTHS ON
CABLE TELEVISION AND IN THE
PUBLIC PRINTS, THE LIST OF
PEOPLE WHO GOT IT WRONG IS
REALLY QUITE EXTENSIVE AND,
YOU KNOW, TO INCLUDE MANY
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS THAT GOT
THE PROSPECT OF DONALD TRUMP
BEING ELECTED IN THE FIRST
PLACE BADLY WRONG.
AND SEEMED NOT TO LEARN VERY
MUCH FROM THAT.
ONE HOPES AND EXPECTS,
PERHAPS, THAT AFTER THIS
DEBACLE AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS IN THE WORST
JOURNALISTIC DEBACLE OF MY
LIFETIME THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME SERIOUS SOUL SEARCHING.
UNFORTUNATELY SO FAR, BRET,
I'M NOT SEEING A LOT OF IT.
I NOTICED A LOT OF OUR CABLE
NEWS COMPETITORS HAVE MOVED
SEEMLESSLY ON TO OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE FOLLOWING SO
OFTEN AS THEY SEEM TO DO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SCRIPT.
REMARKABLE.
>> Bret: YOU THINK IT WAS
WORSE THAN THE IRAQ W.M.D.
COVERAGE?
>> I DO BECAUSE I THINK THE
IRAQ WMD COVERAGE WAS DRIVEN
BY INTELLIGENCE FAILURE.
IT WAS NOT A FAILURE BY
JOURNALISTS AND PEOPLE
BELIEVED SADDAM HUSSEIN HAD
WMD BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, EVERY
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE IN THE
EARTH BASICALLY THOUGHT THE
SAME THING.
EVERY VOICE IN CONGRESS SAID
THE SAME THING.
AND YOU KNOW, AND HE NEVER
REALLY QUITE DENIED IT IN
FACT, HE BEHAVED AS IF HE
HAD THEM ALL ALONG.
AND SO, I THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, SO REPORTERS AND
REPORTERS MOSTLY REPORTED
WHAT OFFICIALS WERE SAYING
ABOUT IT THE OFFICIALS
TURNED OUT TO BE WRONG
BECAUSE THE INTELLIGENCE WAS
WRONG.
A LOT OF WHAT WE SAW HERE
WAS NOT JUST REPORTING.
>> Bret: YEAH.
YOU HAD SO MANY ANONYMOUS
SOURCES FLYING ALL KINDS OF
THINGS, IT SEEMED, UP A FLAG
POLE EVERY DAY IN DIFFERENT
PAPERS AND THEN YOU HAD
FORMER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS WHO WERE HIRED BY
CABLE OUTLETS LIKE THE
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR BRENNAN.
THE FORMER NEGLIGENCE
DIRECTOR, CLAPPER WHO WILL
WERE SAYING EXTRAORDINARY
THINGS ON THE AIR.
>> BRENNAN APPARENTLY SAID
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF
WELL MAYBE HE WAS
MISINFORMED AND THIS DIDN'T
TURN OUT QUITE THE WAY HE
EXPECTED IT TO.
WELL, I GUESS.
AND, YOU KNOW, THOSE GUYS
HAVE A LOT TO ANSWER FOR TOO
IT SEEMS TO ME.
SO DO THE NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CREDULOUSLY PUT ON THE
AIR WHAT THEY HAD TO SAY
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENTIARY
SUPPORT.
IT WAS REALLY QUITE
REMARKABLE, BRET.
>> Bret: LAST THING,
QUICKLY, SPEAKING OF OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN, HOW
ABOUT THIS NEWS ABOUT
MICHAEL AVENATTI, AFTER HE
APPEARED OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN ON SOME OF THOSE
CHANNELS?
>> HE CERTAINLY DID, BRET.
HE WAS BY ONE COUNT, HE WAS
ON CNN AND MSNBC 108 TIMES
BETWEEN MARCH AND MAY OF
LAST YEAR AND HE WAS BEING
TAKEN SERIOUSLY ON THE AIR
AS A PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
AND YOU WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
THAT A GUY LIKE THIS WITH
THE DODGY ACCUSATIONS THAT
HE MADE AND SO ON THAT
SOMEBODY IN THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD HAVE
SMELLED A RAT AND THOUGHT
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T BE
PUBLICIZING THIS GUY.
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T BE HAVING
THIS GUY ON ALL THE TIME.
BUT HE HAD ONE THING THAT
THEY WANTED AND THAT WAS HE
WAS VERY MUCH ANTI-TRUMP AND
THEY WERE, TOO, AND THE
RESULT WAS WHAT YOU SEE